a display of the world's finest aircraft
a look into what's on the market and how
these machines are impacting global
travel
the singapore air show takes place every
two years but this is the first time
it's being held during the pandemic
we all know
in this current environment uh yes it
the attendance should surely be lower
that's the that's the um
i think that's all of us will expect
that
but as far as the quality is concerned
i'm not worried about that
because
here we have assembled a high quality
set of exhibitors more than 70 percent
of the top 20 global aerospace companies
are here
key players such as boeing airbus and
engine makers rolls-royce will still be
attending and the show will be a rare
opportunity to hold in-person meetings
with customers to drum up new business
but with asia pacific battling a fierce
wave of the omicron variant the four-day
air show will still be relatively muted
a parallel to the reality of the travel
sector in this part of the world
while the united states and europe have
eased restrictions and demand has
rebounded asia lags far behind foreign
tourists are barred from entering and
mandatory quarantines are still in place
in many countries
we are starting to see green shoots in
the industry
like passenger travel numbers are up
flight frequencies are up i think we can
all sense the
the pent-up demand for travel
we also can see and sense optimism
there are positive signs for 2022.
several places such as australia new
zealand and the philippines are lifting
bans on overseas visitors but industry
figures warn there's a long way to go
leah harding al jazeera